track-and-field is stepping into all new
territory for the first time ever the
World Athletics Championships are
heading to the Middle East for ten days
Cathars capital city Doha will be a
focal point for global sport just as the
whole country will be when the football
World Cup lands in three is time twenty
two is very important for us and we know
that because of the media everybody is
coming here we want to show the people
in advance how other is prepared for the
2022 but I believe what championship is
is a reason is is an idea bites in the
championships have been moved from their
regular slot in August to avoid the peak
temperatures of Qatar summer and while
the men's and women's marathons will
start at midnight to further counter the
heat organizers except it will still be
a challenge to keep runners cool on the
streets of Doha actually you can deal
with heat but humidity is is really a
challenge so we will watch all those
metrics we do have extra precautions we
do have extra stuff out on the course
more medical support more water but yes
it is going to be tough
there'll be a very different feel for
the majority of events an air cooling
system inside the main Khalifa Stadium
will ensure the temperature there hovers
at around 25 degrees Celsius I know
there was a lot of talk before coming
here whether or not it was smart to do
that but I mean it feels great in there
and I think it's just going to make four
I mean the fact that they can control
the temperature in the stadium is just
unbelievable I had the privilege of
racing here before and I felt the
cooling system and actually loves it I'm
as a sprinter I don't think it Aqaba
affect us as much but I'm definitely
happy that my parents were able to sit
in the AC a heated debate that won't be
repeated at the football World Cup the
2022 tournament will be held in the far
cooler months of November and December
Andy Richardson al Jazeera